lo primero es que Londres el gobierno
central en Westminster puede respirar
tranquilo no habrá un segundo referendo
de Independencia el 19 de octubre de
2023 como lo había planteado el gobierno
escocés y sin duda es un golpe duro para
los nacionalistas escoceses pero no una
batalla política perdida en esta larga
camino en esta larga jornada en este el
asunto más grande de la política
escocesa y lejos de debilitar
políticamente a Nicolás Torres la
ministra principal escocesa parece que
le está dando más impulso como lo
mencionas ha dicho que está decepcionada
con este fallo que venía venir este
resultado Pero ha dicho además que una
ley que no permite que Escocia elija su
propio futuro sin el consentimiento de
Westminster expone como un mito
cualquier noción de que el Reino Unido
es una asociación voluntaria y ha
agregado además que en una democracia
Dios no puede y no será silenciada por
ellos se espera que en las próximas
horas Nicolás Torres en una declaración
de más detalles sobre Cuáles son los
pasos a seguir en esa que es su quimera
su sueño y es lograr la independencia
escocesa del Reino Unido bueno Y ante
esto le pregunto si Entonces el gobierno
de ustedes puede intentar promover este
segundo referendo para el año que viene
como lo tenían pensado
en este momento no existe esa
posibilidad ni jurídica ni políticamente
Pese a que Nicolás torjollón quiere
tratar de disuadir al Primer Ministro
Richie sunat para que Westminster le
conceda al parlamento escocés el permiso
de tratar asuntos constitucionales y
poder adelantar un segundo referéndum de
Independencia esa es una posibilidad
bastante poco probable pero Nicolás
Target ha dicho en el pasado que si el
fallo sería negativo contra los
nacionalistas escoceses entonces en las
elecciones generales que probablemente
se realizarán en el año 2024 estas si
los nacionalistas obtienen las mayorías
nuevamente en el parlamento escocés
podrían convertirse en un referendo de
facto Sin embargo como sabemos y
especialmente por lo que ha pasado este
año en el Reino Unido un año en política
puede ser mucho así que habrá que
esperar entretando esta tarde se tiene
previstas marchas para exigir la
tendencia escocesa en diferentes
ciudades de